hey everyone
and welcome to this new video of simply
learn on proof of work in blockchain
in this video we are going to cover all
important concepts
and components related to proof of work
first
we will have a quick introduction of
blockchain then
we will understand what is proof of work
then we will look into how does it works
and after that we will explore why is it
actually needed
what are the issues faced by proof of
work
and at last we will look into the
blockchains working with proof of work
so without further delay let's get
started with the video
but before that let's have a quick
introduction to blockchain
the term blockchain refers to a
decentralized database
that is made up of sequential blocks
that contain recorded data
the database is backed up by a network
of self-contained participants
known as nodes now let's
understand what is proof of work
proof of work is a decentralized
consensus method
that requires network participants to
spend time
solving an arbitrary mathematical puzzle
in order to prevent the system from
being hacked
it is widely used in cryptocurrency
mining for validating transactions and
mining new tokens
it helps in the processing of
peer-to-peer transactions
securely without the need of a trusted
third party
it also requires huge amount of energy
at scale
which only increases as more miners join
the network
now let's have a look at how proof of
work works
the right to add new blocks to a proof
of work blockchain
is provided to individuals who are
willing to expand computational
resources
to solve cryptographic issues
the participants competing to add new
blocks are referred to as miners
and the process is referred to as mining
miners are the one who execute proof of
work miners
use their computational power to locate
a valid block
when a piece of information such as a
transaction
needs to be added to the blockchain
this is accomplished by locating a hash
that meets the network protocol
specific requirements in cryptography
a hash is the outcome of a hash function
it converts any format or size of data
into fixed size
numbers the protocol
established a level of mining difficulty
that is
algorithmically adjusted so that the
time it takes to obtain a proper hash
averages 10 minutes miners can sometimes
locate multiple blocks
that satisfy the protocol's requirements
at the same time
and split the chain n into
because there can be only one accurate
chain the protocol must
account for these circumstances miners
will initially continue
to mine on both chains but once another
block is discovered on top of one of the
two prior blocks
that chain becomes the canonical chain
and miners are economically incentivized
to discard the other block
one of the advantages of proof of work
blockchain in terms of security
is their resilience to civil attacks the
civil attacks
occurs when one player in the network
generates many false identities in the
order to get an unfair edge
over other network participants who only
have one identity
51 attacks occur when a single user
takes control of more than 51 percent of
the network's resources
and hence has control over the adding of
new blocks
now we know how proof of work works
let's dive down deeper
and explore why do we need proof of work
majorly proof of work is required for
security
and fraud prevention as well as trust
proof of work is intended to prevent
users from printing coins
they didn't earn or from double spending
if users could spend their coins more
than once the currency would
effectively become worthless proof of
work ensures
that independent data processors or
miners
can't lie about a transaction
linking a block with the proof of work
hash of its
predecessor results in tamper resistance
because the hash of each block is an
ingredient
in the hash of the following block any
changes in the chain will
affect the final proof of work hash
as well as all block hashes in between
so the deeper the altered block
the more computational effort needed for
tampering
the first miner who discovers the proof
of work
answers publishes the solution to the
rest of the network
when a new block is discovered all nodes
are notified
we check the answer twice before moving
on to the next block
ps if correct the block miners earn the
transaction fees
and the block reward
the protocol only accepts the longest
chain as valid and authentic
a fake chain is impractical in the long
run since a minus chances of receiving
the block reward and minimal
other miners will continue to extend the
valid chain quicker
than the tampered chain over time
moving on let's have a look at the other
side of the coin
as well as understand some of the major
issues with proof of work
first is it has a negative impact on the
environment
second the 51 attack can be used against
it
if miners gain control of 51 of the
hashing power
they will be able to determine what is
true
aside from the enormous cost of price
there is no mechanism in place to punish
any malicious miners
and four because every node must process
every transaction
it does not scale properly while
sharding the network may boost
efficiency
it also reduces security this was all
about proof of work
let's explore the best blockchain
networks working with proof of work
bitcoin is the largest and the very
first blockchain to adopt proof of work
and work with it ethereum is next
working with proof of work
though it is aiming to switch to proof
of stake which we will talk about in a
coming video
then comes bitcoin cash which is an
extension of bitcoin
and follows the same structure thus it
also works on proof of work
then come litecoin which is also an
altcoin of bitcoin
and then comes monero another
cryptocurrency serving similar purpose
as other cryptos
well this is all about proof of work in
blockchain we have almost reached the
end of this video
if i missed anything important do let me
know in the comment section
i hope you enjoyed this video on proof
of work in blockchain and learn
something new from it
if you like this video then please do
hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here